hi and welcome to episode number 39 of
the weekly group la platform podcast I
am Franciscan boy and I'm here with my
colleague nut mark Mandel who are you hi
I'm Chris you might remember me from
such shows as episode 33 I think I the
one of our girl I don't know which one
he was Oh Missy anyway I'm the token
Australian on the show and yeah whenever
mark is not here we replace him with
another Australian so we had a episode
25 25 episode 25 with Andrew joining
chris bradford way too many australians
that time this time there's only one so
yeah mark is still traveling somewhere
in australia and join the holidays so
instead we have chris and we're going to
be talking today about PHP with chris
but also with two other coworkers Terry
Ryan and branch a fur and then after
that once we done discussing all the
possible things you can do with PHP on
google a platform will have a question
of the week and the question of the week
these week is about about networking so
the question is okay so I want to use
web sockets on a load balancer and I'm
using an HTTPS love to answer how do I
do that and so we'll have a we have an
answer for that at the end of the
episode but before that we're going to
have the cool thing of the week and the
cool thing of the week is about
printable machines a printable VMS why
don't you tell us a little bit about
about that alright so this week we
announced that we're dropping prices for
pre-emptive all VMS by up to thirty
three percent nice yes is this is really
great I haven't really used pre-emptive
all VMS very much but after reading this
I'm kind of excited about it again yeah
now they're very good especially so
basically the a pre-emptive all machine
a free end to vm is an AVM that can be
preempted obviously and has the limit
that it cannot run more than 24 hours so
regardless of what happens after for 24
hours it will be shut down but it could
be shut down
than that but you cannot you have the
power to react to that there's actually
a restive via an API call that is done
before it's shut down okay you can shut
down gracefully if you need to really
some resources or whatever you can toy
with that it's really great for anything
like patchwork or some processing or
something like that maybe your
processing logs you know every six hours
or something like that yeah there's so
if you're running anything like
mapreduce style like spark Hadoop or
whatever or if you're doing things like
patch work like we know we have zinc for
instance they use it to render movies
rendering a movie takes a lot of
computation time but it is not something
urgent right so say makes it much much
more affordable to do it with
winterville machines especially now and
even though these prices have dropped
thirty three percent they're already
much much cheaper than the regular vm
yeah so it really pays off to write
these kind of jobs in a way that are
robust so you know if the Machine goes
down your code doesn't really I mean to
worry about that for you should be
writing you a call like that anyway yeah
definitely I mean things just happen
right maybe I network links go down or
you know data center catches on fire or
something like that like things how
Sheen's just go away some so so yeah but
but yeah if your if your application is
already designed that way check it out
we have a link to the blog post
announcing the the new prices on the
show notes as usual cool so I think that
is time to go talk with our friends
Therrien brent great let's talk PHP so
we're very excited to have you today our
two co-workers Terry Ryan and Brent
Shaffer hey housing it's going great
yeah how you guys very happy to have you
so yeah very happy to have you because
you're the only two people that I know
the like PHP so you mean you just gotta
lure people yeah I could go in Jackie I
don't lots of people that like PHP yeah
we're not very well represented yeah
there's well there's nothing many so I
think it is important to have you
represented on the podcast so before we
start talking about PHP and how awesome
it is or not why don't you tell us a
little bit about who you are what do you
do at Google
Terry sure so I'm like France s come on
the DEA team I go out and talk to
developers I specifically spent a lot of
time with PHP community going to PHP
events and trying to trying to get out
the message that we at Google have PHP
solutions on Google cloud platform cool
could use a little bit more about your
experience with PHP like I think you
used to do a lot of PHP before joining
ago sir yep so before I worked for
Google i worked for adobe and all of the
web work i did adobe more was all PHP
and then before that i spent some time
at the Wharton School the universe
Pennsylvania and a lot of our public
stuff was PHP in addition to other
languages cool what about you Brett
Brent yeah I so I'm a DBE like Chris and
I that means that i'm i'm a i'm an
engineer but i'm more on the side of our
end users so i spent a lot of time on
github and i do a lot of work
integrating with our platform and trying
to make that process easier for the
developers that are using our products
so specifically i've been working on a
lot of the PHP libraries that we have on
github and historically I've been I have
a PHP background which is one of the
reasons why I was picked for this role
and and I actually do like PHP I
whenever I started developing PHP it was
it was a it was the first dynamic
language that I had used and previously
I'd been programming in Java and C sharp
so I loved it and I was also fortunate
enough to learn from some developers
that actually had good coding coding
practices and standards and so I started
learning on the symphony framework which
those guys are really really solid
developers and so I I was luckily able
to fall into the the part of the peach p
community that has really really solid
developers and programming practices
cool so everything I know about PHP and
Google cloud platform is basically what
you can find our cloud the google com /
PHP why didn't you tell us a little bit
about so yeah if I was a PHP developer
and I get to google google
platform whether they have in my
disposal well we have the wide range of
all of google hub platform but
specifically focused on computing
resources it would be app engine compute
engine and container engine for App
Engine PHP is one of those standard
languages that runs on App Engine
standard which means that you can take
PHP code they use in other places plop
it down and it will run right within the
context of App Engine relatively easily
of all the languages that are ported
code over from from non App Engine to
App Engine but I feel like the PHP
implementations a little the lightest
like in terms of what you have to change
like you have to change like a couple
places where you pointed to the file
system was on App Engine you can't yeah
but you get rid of those calls and for
the most part a lot of your PHP code is
just going to work it's really really
kind of fantastic so we've got app
engine standard we also have an app
engine flexible runtime PHP is supported
on both of those edition compute engine
and container engine cool so for PHP
standard center environment or nap
engine do you can you use any kind of
framework like you were talking about
symphony is that's something that
developers can just use directly that's
a good question so we we do support some
of the larger frameworks out there like
for instance WordPress runs really well
in a pigeon standard because we've put a
lot of effort into making that an easy
process to get up and running we also
have some documentation for getting
symphony up and running so there are a
lot of restrictions and App Engine
classic because it's a sandbox
environment so anybody that's using
another framework out there there's
quite a few with PHP it's not like the
Ruby community where they've you know
all kind of agreed on one or two
framework sirs there's just a ton of PHP
framework so yeah we don't have
tutorials out there for every single one
but I think it is worth you know trying
to deploy an app engine standard we have
a lot of good documentation on what is
and isn't supported for the PHP standard
or App Engine standard PHP runtime so
for instance you know if you know you
need a certain extension you should
check the documentation and if it's not
available in a pigeon standard then you
want to run that framework in
in App Engine flexible environment give
some examples of things that might not
work well for the longest time like
imagemagick right wasn't supported but
we now support that so that's going away
at oh yeah problem we did in the last
big rev of PHP on App Engine fix a lot
of the like the most requested things
that were missing so I I I don't know if
the top of my head something that would
be it would be something that you know
not you know a not widely used used tool
so the majority of applications will run
just fine well yeah I mean and there's a
lot of file systems that are a lot of
frameworks that require the file system
by default out of the box so I guess
it's more like it's not a question of
whether it will run on App Engine it's a
question of how much work would be
required to get it to the point where
able to run an app engine and and and
that varies per framework so for
instance the WordPress and the symphony
tutorials we have we've we've gone ahead
and we've made sure we take care of that
kind of stuff for you but for laravel
for cakephp we're still working on
getting those solutions out there so you
don't have to do it yourselves and for
somebody that's come new to the platform
that deployed one of these frameworks
that might be a frustrating process at
first trying to you know tweak the knobs
of the framework to get it to run as I
say the big thing that I've run into is
though as you point out that they need
the file system and I find they need the
file system to write a configuration
however once that configuration file is
written it's not going to it doesn't
actively edit that configuration every
time the app runs it's like a one-time
thing and so if you can get them set
correctly in development and push to
production you typically are okay that's
been my experience with the couple of
frameworks that I've experimented with
and not some of the bigger ones like
lumen and lumen like those types of
frameworks yeah so I've found that the
frameworks that generate configuration
for their production environment it's
very difficult to get them to generate
correctly in a dev environment and so
what I've typically done is you use
Google Cloud storage as a file system
and because you have a stream wrapper so
you can instead of saying you know these
files are going to be written to
do you know cash / you know templates
you just say these files can be written
2g GS colon slash slash you know bucket
name / cash and then it all will
actually function as you would expect it
to function and so I guess that would be
a [ __ ] cash as well across getting ones
so so what's the best way for someone to
get started and to use cloud storage for
that well they could look at the
symphony starter project we have the
stream wrappers being used as a shared
cache in that project the WordPress
there there's a github repository that
we have all of these framework samples
in there's a there's a wordpress one
that does the same thing so yeah there's
a couple examples of us doing that cool
so all of these restorations are we
talking about they are related to App
Engine standard environment yes do we
have any problem running your PHP on
flexible environment yeah so we've been
working really hard on the App Engine
flexible runtime for PHP and that's
something that builds and docker and so
it's really portable and it's really
great you can run it in Coober Nettie's
cluster and we have some pretty cool
docs on how to do that also running
microservices and you know multiple
services that are communicating with
each other in an Akubra Nettie's cluster
and also in epogen flexible because
since that mission flexible runs docker
container images it's they're all
compatible which is nice that runtime is
it's on github and it's in the
repository a Google cloud platform / PHP
dash talker but it is it is almost in
alpha so we have a lot of Doc's we have
a lot of you know stuff and we're
putting a lot of time into making it
good but I think it's important to note
it's still in alpha so or it's not quite
now foot it's almost awful it'll be
maybe maybe by the time this goes live
it will be in alpha cool yeah now this
is coming out next week so I don't know
i don't know how fast you are but we
have the challenge now cool so you
mentioned goober Nettie's that is
actually something that our audience
loves like we keep on talking about crew
benetti's in rural container engine
basically every episode no thanks how is
the experience like I know a lot of
people that come to PHP because of the
lamp stack like that p and the lamp is
PHP or Python upper apparently according
to what just read rising but yeah so if
i come from lamp stack what is the best
place to run it could it be a standard
app engine could be flexible attention
could be container engine complete
engine i think the answer is going to
depend right so if you're coming from a
a running a lap stop steckbox right yeah
the first thing you gotta say it's like
that anymore but if you're if you're for
whatever reason you know your friend set
up not you your friends that a B'nai are
responsible for it right so we have in
compute engine lamp stack images in
cloud launcher right so you want to get
you wanna get started on lamp like boom
you just run a cloud launcher and you're
there what is the best way to do it it's
going to depend if you are moving
towards the containerized workload then
i would definitely tell you to look at
cooper Nettie's and container engine and
splitting it up that way with the caveat
that the m is going to be the
problematic part of that right that
Corinne DS and containers and persistent
database doesn't always it's not always
a good combo right and then you're
trading in one disaster for another so
you know I would say look at getting you
know hey you can go you have a lot of
options right you can go App Engine
either standard or flexible running
Cloud sequel and that solves a lot of
the problems for you you can go with
Cooper Nettie's and cloud and cloud
sequel or you can run your full my
sequel on Cooper Nettie's as a pet I
would not recommend that i would i would
say go without sequel for the the m part
and then it's going to depend are you
moving the containers then you know then
then container engine would probably be
the best place for you to look are you
anticipating incredible amounts of scale
or incredibly variable amounts of scale
or make sense we're App Engine really
shines well then obviously I go App
Engine are you are you in that scenario
and you know go the full the flow flow
diagram here during that scenario and
you need to run bits that won't run on
App Engine standard for whatever reason
then flexible is probably what you want
to do with the caveat that it is
currently pre-alpha we don't even have a
name for it so that I mean that would
how I would go through the whole
explanation and that's how I talk to a
customer about it if they were
interested yeah i think if you if you're
an existing app that's like you know
pretty sizable using a GC instance just
you know vm and possibly using the the
lamp deployment it's going to be the
easiest way to get your app up and
running but if you're coming at it with
a fresh application i would definitely
encourage container icing first with
with with flexible because it's such an
easy move from flex to cooper Nettie's
and so if you think your scale you may
require scale eventually it's really
nice way to go not to mention just the
portability you get from containers and
images is really nice as it you know and
this operon junoon one of the things
that's come up when I've talked about
goober Nettie's is that idea of like so
you have the lamp stack and the you know
the the code is all you know looking at
itself looking everything as level host
one of the great things about Cooper
Nettie's is that you can run multiple
containers on the same in the same pod
as offering localhost and that is
there's a nice bridging stepping stone
towards getting to a better place with
with your with your app is moving into
Cooper Nettie's and you know taking
advantage of the the fact that you can't
analyze it but also leave the code non
containerized not ideal but most of
these are bridging solutions anyway so
what's the best way for someone to use
something like engine acts as a as I oh
yeah I was actually trying to work this
in the conversation so we we don't have
a lamp stack but we do have more or less
a lamp stack right it's a the Blues on
flex unfledged right yeah so flex uses
engine X
Francis can I trying to get 10 names
engine X instead of Apache yeah it's the
how do you pronounce that lies the
nuances the pronunciation might have
been lost okay womp and leap no I don't
know um yet so we use engine X and and
then the M you know cloud cloud sequel
works exactly like a my sequel instance
so it works so n krates perfectly so you
know and just to just to disambiguate
big your eyes that's on the App Engine
flexible run time when I said earlier
about cloud launcher we do have full on
lamp stack boxes and cloud launcher but
no just given all our acronyms I'm
actually curious about when you have the
cloud launcher do we also have things
that depend directly on my seat on cloud
sequel or do they all start one instance
which is like the sequel instance as far
as I know none of them point to cloud
sequels radical solution doesn't you
can't it just means that out of box here
don't configure it a little bit cool
yeah I think that that is something that
most people regardless up if they do PHP
or not they should consider is Brion
brandd running your own sequel databases
consider cloud sequel version sure is so
much better it is really fast and scales
you can actually make the disk bigger
yeah which is magic like that is amazing
you don't need to migrate and have weird
like moments where you need to make your
database read-only so you can migrate to
something else it just it just works
it's easy to set up replicas it's easy
to set up near line near line backups
it's now God's equal to v2 is Magic with
the caveat that it is not yet GA
pre-alpha it's not it's it's still not
GA which again from I mean it's been
running a long time and it's really
stable install these great things but if
you are a company or you you need an SLA
yeah have an SLA on it so it's one thing
to but if you look like it's very clear
from the be wife low right go to it it's
like um dr e to write or theirs
yeah that down there the buds yeah um so
we we definitely I think want to push
people to v2 but you know make sure that
people understand that the SLA is not
there yet and had left coast crest is
that a big thing in the PHP community no
I don't so not something more bigger
than Ruby community and we do have
collected apply postgres instances and
you know p do the the database
abstraction library for PHP supports
postgres too so it's definitely there if
people want to use it great and so other
than running apps what else is new in
terms of PHP on cloud oh you mean well
so we are working on a pretty nice
library that people can use to access
the cloud api's and that again you know
one of the great thing about the PHP
spaces it's rapidly developing and it's
getting better unfortunately that means
that a lot of stuff we're talking about
is still in pre-alpha / you know not GA
states but one of those things is our
our cloud library and we have a lot of
really nice ap is a really nice wrappers
for AP is that you can use to manage you
know pub/sub bigquery datastore what
Euclid everything the new library of the
vision the vision API Asians in there
and yeah natural language api is in
there there's like there's a whole i
mean i'm pretty much every cloud API has
a wrapper in PHP now and they're all
really really nice to use and really
easy to understand compared to the
previous stuff so are those robbers
wrapping the wheat JP either wiping out
the wrapping the rest api or the grp
capi yeah good question so they're
wrapping the rest api right now the gr
pc support is definitely planned it's um
scheduled for before the end of the year
so it should have both and and then yeah
we'll be able to multiplex on on on one
or the other depending on if you have
the gerb is any extension installed cool
ND king of GOP see what's the state of
that in PHP yeah yeah so it's supported
again to you know Google investing in
PHP you had you you can use pekel which
is the PHP extension manager so if you
do pekel install
grp see it'll compile the sea extension
and and then once you have that it you
know you enable that a/c extension and
then you can use grp see and that's on
PHP on compute engine right you can do
that in compute engine yeah when you do
it on App Engine as well I have I
haven't tried it yet so those curious so
you could definitely do it with a custom
runtime we are going to build it build
your pc into the supported runtime at
some point for sure cool so we're kind
of running out of time is there any
other topic that you like to discuss
before we finish so I had one I just
wanted to mention one of the things is
really nice about using the runtimes
that we're trying to provide is they
we're trying we're trying to tackle the
the misconception that PHP is not a
secure language so we're spending a lot
of time making the runtime secure by
default and that means we've done things
like we've patched core PHP functions
that might have some really unsafe
operations and properties one instance
of that is there's like a parse string
function that people use to parks query
strings you can be used improperly in a
way that would overwrite global
variables and then you know thus be a
really really large threat vector and so
we've patched PHP to not allow that
there's also there's security extensions
once called su hosen that we use and
that does the same thing of blacklisting
a lot of the functions that are
traditionally used you know abused in
PHP and you can you can still use them
you can whitelist them by setting an
environment variable but they are
secured they are locked down by default
so there's a couple other things we do
in that same vein one of them kind of
being you know using engine X and and
trying to do the things that maybe the
aren't as largely accepted in PHP
community as they are in other language
communities and so we're trying to bring
those to PHP developers without them
having to
opt in or whatever else cool what about
you Terry is anything else that you
would like to mention well I think I
mentioned is that you know Brent's teen
does ought to work on on the AP is and
one of the things I really appreciate
about them is that they're very clearly
written by people that write PHP and not
like oh here's the here's the Python
implementation in PHP that's all on
github I don't know how how how
accepting of of outside input are we in
are we with them oh definitely like yeah
yeah so yeah in contributions we were
like super super excited so yeah so if
anybody's out there and they're they're
fooling around with these things and
find either a you know not not that
there would be a problem right right but
you know when developers hear me know
ago so we would definitely welcome any
contributions yeah I know all this stuff
is at an early stage so a lot of there's
there's a couple of guides that that
have given us suggestions and their
input goes a long way because we are
still making a lot of decisions on how
we're going to move forward with these
run times and and all this stuff so nice
so one last question what is the best
place for PHP developers to start using
google app Google cloud platform cloud
google com /p P is he so thank you very
much to youtube for taking the time
today to talk to us about PHP and
everything you can do a little claw
platform yeah thanks go PHP yay thanks
thanks again to Terry and Brent that was
really great I learned a lot about PHP
yeah I didn't know much but I PHP but I
almost want to try it now almost no more
there ya go so it's time to go with our
question of the week and the question of
the week this week is something that I'm
not a master on as I have said many
times and I'm not a network expert at
all but it is something that it is
pretty interesting so we have the hcps
load balancer which is a little dancer
that works globally so basically it does
routing and it sends for whatever
request you get for an HTTP request
you'll be able to send it to the closest
instance
group that you have running so yeah so
if you send a request from coming from
Barcelona for instance we'll go to the
data center that we have in Belgium but
if you send it from San Francisco go to
the new data center in the rescues yeah
yeah but it has a restriction which is
it doesn't support web sockets right and
this is because WebSockets aren't HTTP
there it's it's it's own protocol which
is somewhat related to http but only in
an older way so it's kind of expected
that the HTTP load balancer doesn't work
with it yeah it is it is really not it's
the B is like more like TCP with some
HTTP sprinkled on top yeah yes but so so
the question is okay so since this is
not supported what do i do if i want to
have web sockets on on our global love
box yeah you certainly want some load
balancing that's quite an expensive
protocol so the solution is to use the
ssl load balancer if you're using ssl
with your web sockets and i do recommend
that yeah and if you're not then you can
also use the TTP load balancer and and
so this is just a more flexible load
balancer that doesn't really care about
high level protocols like HTTP so this
could be used for any sort of protocol
that happens over tcp cool so so
basically if you move to DCP to the tcp
load balancer you will be losing the
fact that you have a global load
balancing right because the tcp load
balancer is actually regional which in
many cases actually totally fine so is
that something that you find with then
yeah just give the tcp load balancer and
web sockets are completely supported but
if not we have these different load
balancer which is the ssl load balancer
that manages ssl obviously that isn't
named but also it does routing across
different regions so you again if you
sin and it's al if a WebSocket started
from Barcelona I got to Belgium but if
it goes from San Francisco you go to I
think it's Oregon or something like yeah
west coast and I guess that's pretty
important for web sockets because they
usually like low latency kind of thing
maybe a game
like an interactive real game or
something if you're using WebSockets
like you're basically trying to do real
time so if you end up in a different
continent yeah the real tense i'm going
to be that real so so yeah so check it
out so we're going to have links from
the show notes to all the documentation
to both the tcp load balancer the HTTPS
load balancer and then finally this
seller dancer and all of the PHP stuff
too in all the PHP stuff lots of links
from there too well thank you so much
Chris for taking the time this week to
know where these amazing episode with me
it was good being marked for a day yeah
it was it was good to keep on having an
Australian accent next to me makes me
feel like home right so yeah again thank
you so much and thank you so much to all
the listeners for being there and talk
to you all next week okay thanks I won't
see you next week
you